la ville épilée 110 continué par les
forces russes depuis plusieurs mois à
barmouth il faut prendre un peu de
hauteur pour constater l'ampleur des
destructions
rue après rue ou du moins ce qu'il en
reste des bâtiments presque tous ces
ventrer
ce déminèrent ukrainien tient à montrer
cette mine car selon lui les soldats de
Moscou sont prêts à tout pour prendre le
contrôle de la ville
parfois ils utilisent même les cadavres
de leur propre soldats pour y cacher des
mines
lorsque nous arrivons dans des tranchées
que nous trouvons des corps il y a des
mines partout
la patrouille se poursuit mais cette
fois-ci à pied
ils le savent tous ne rentreront pas
chez eux après cette mission
au détour d'une maison quelques tirs
pour fixer l'ennemi
avant que celui-ci ne réponde
il faut désormais recharger les armes
avant de repartir au combat
inexorablement
à barmouth la pression sur les épaules
des soldats Ukrainiens moins nombreux
que les Russes et constante
il s'agit principalement de tir
d'artillerie et de mortier mais cela ne
s'arrête pas là des drones larguent
également des grenades et bien sûr il y
a aussi des combats de rue et des tirs
de mitrailleuse si tu es dans l'aublaste
de Donetsk la ville et la priorité de
yefghani prigogne le chef de Wagner
désireux d'apporter une victoire
militaire ne serait-ce que symbolique
sur la table de Vladimir Poutine